[Music]
am i dad you're in a coma you mean this
is all a dream
memories everywhere Nicole now goes to
the same column space
here in a coma some people develop
unique abilities but to discover those
abilities a person need a party
needs to be put in danger now maybe
we'll see what your ability will be
the man from the balcony is he the
leader he taught us how to survive we're
here for a reason everyone who's here
didn't make it in reality
they didn't have a future there you
haven't figured out nothing else
I'm the one in charge here
this world is made of memories how did
they get here there's an island for your
Reapers somewhere in the coma
we're always looking for people who can
help us get there
is this my life now I remember that I
couldn't be together with who I wanted
to be here it's possible
our world would never appreciate
something unusual even if it's a hundred
times better
what do you mean reality for after that
we need to wake up you can't wake up do
you understand
your body is their income you are here
there's nothing you can do about it
life in coma is as real as it gets I
said hold it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]